a well-told story should feel almost
like a roller coaster ride yeah I I
believe that I think that
a well-told story has ups and downs and
it has twists and turns and it surprises
and delights you and terrifies you
um I think that a really well told story
should have that variety of emotions uh
and I think that when you think about
some of your favorite movies and books
and experiences they really take you on
that Journey from beginning middle and
end
they take you on a journey where you
truly Let Yourself Go you are present
you suspend your disbelief and you trust
that the Storyteller and Creator is
going to take you on this magical
journey and it's not just about the
Thrills and the screams and the
excitement but it's about that
anticipation you think about a roller
coaster from the moment that you're
lining up to get on the vehicle itself
your heart art is beating you're excited
talking to your family and your friends
um you're trying to you know you're so
pumped up and excited to go on this
adventure and even when you climb into
the vehicle and you have your safety on
you and everything
going off of that ramp and you know when
you start chugging up the track it's
you're not thinking about anything else
you know you're thinking about oh my
gosh I'm just gonna go on this really
fast ride and there's nothing I can do
I'm out of control right I have to trust
that this coaster is going to take me
back safely to where I started but for
those few moments you really let
yourself go and be present and just
enjoy the ride and I feel like
well-told stories do that right you
trust that you're going to be taken to
some extraordinary place
to go on your hero's journey if you will
and really depart on this and embark on
this adventure where you have this
excitement and this anticipation
and you go on a thrilling you know
twists and turns and ups and downs and
all kinds of things that you don't have
control over and you're surprised by how
not only you know you survive in the end
that you had a great time but it's this
feeling of
I think this this this release of
control that is extremely perhaps very
exciting for a lot of people because
all your life
um for the most part you have to really
think about what you're doing and
planning and you know it's a checklist
of things to do and accomplish and all
of these things and sometimes it just
feels good to let someone else take
control for a little bit and take you on
this really great journey and that's why
I think a lot of people come back to
like theme parks and amusement parks and
everything because it's a way for you to
truly
um
you know let yourself play and Release
Yourself from all these inhibitions and
um engage in something that feels
extraordinary that is not is out of the
ordinary life that you live and being
able to transport yourself to this
playful
um you know playground of sorts where
you can really go on an adventure is
something that
um a well-told story does
and the the beauty of it is it's not
thrill every minute there's Peaks and
valleys too and yeah and there are a lot
of Peaks and valleys in Wilton stories I
mean you know well-toed stories make you
cry as much as you laugh right
um they touch you they you know some
stories can be extremely tragic but uh
there's a glimmer of hope in the end
um so all of these emotions of positive
and negative emotions and neither you
know they're not good or bad they're
just the scale of emotions the spectrum
of emotions that we as human beings
experience
um and so when I think about
you know going on a roller coaster
um it's really you know a metaphor to
the the life of um you know the Journey
of a well-tooled story in which there
are these Peaks and valleys and there
are ups and downs and all of them are
okay you know it's okay to be sad it's
okay to cry it's okay to feel to feel
scared and terrified because that is The
Human Experience
um and I think that if you know you live
your life wanting to experience
uh the peak all the time
then you haven't truly lived you haven't
you know experienced all that life has
to offer for you and that's why really
great stories take you there and make
you really reflect on
um you know all the various emotions
that you can experience in your life and
how you can reflect upon it
um in your own life with it with your
own family and friends and how you can
experience this colorful spectrum that
is life
where does the creative process begin
for an immersive story
the creative process begins with a lot
of research that's something that I
think everyone
should always do as a step one if you
are going to tell a story especially a
story that's not yours to own
um I think that really understanding
the subject matter talking to experts
and having
the appropriate
subject matter experts and advisors to
help you truly understand a topic and a
world is extremely important I think
that if you jump into the creative
process without understanding
the context the significance you know
what's important about that particular
story
is can be very problematic so I always
want to find
um multiple perspectives on a particular
subject matter or topic or World
whatever it is to truly understand
especially if it's non-fiction
especially if it's something
biographical especially if it's
historical or educational
even if it's not even if it's a
fictional World
um you have to respect
uh the subject matter and the story so I
think that research is
um number one the first step that you
must take as a Storyteller to any
project that you work on
can you talk about the brainstorming
process
you know there's so many different ways
to brainstorm an idea but I think as a
creative process and as creatives and
creative collaborators it's a really
great way to all be together in a room
when you brainstorm an idea and it
depending on the scope of your project
and the kind of project that you have
you may bring in some different
disciplines to really think about your
world through their various skill set so
you might have an illustrator or an
architect or a writer or a creative
director or a landscape designer it
really depends on the subject matter
that you're working with but ultimately
you want to have all these various
Representatives if you will of all these
creative disciplines come together so
that you're able to create something
that is seamless and integrated because
you're using multiple senses to
experience an immersive story you want
to make sure that all of these voices
are present in the room at the table
cultural experts um story uh you know
subject matter experts all of these
things it's a way for you to really
throw out all the ideas and brainstorm
all the good and bad ideas together so
that you can really understand
what's important about the story you
want to share with the world and hearing
it from all these different disciplines
and from different people and voices is
extremely important to make sure that
you have a very diverse and
representative uh representation of a
story that is truly unique and authentic
and on the flip side though let's take
an example of like you know the the
quote too many cooks spoiled broth so if
we have too many people how does it
dilute it I mean when do you know I
think I have a good mix
you know that's a really uh it's a good
question and I think that a lot of times
um
we you want to it really depends on what
we're talking about because there are
certain instances where you feel like
you really want to focus on an idea or a
topic and really brainstorm from that
idea but sometimes I think that it's
good to start out it's good to start out
bigger in some sense and maybe you
narrow it down from there
um I think that it's important to have
important voices heard in the beginning
because that really shapes how you
create that story
um throughout the
life cycle of a project and
it really gives you you know as the
Creator a Storyteller you want to at
least for me personally I want to hear
everyone's ideas and as the story
Champion as the person who's going to
create the story I want to make sure
that all the voices within that within
the team are heard first and foremost
and in a way my job is to be a curator
to decide which of these perspectives
are the ones that we really want to
focus on which are the ones that are
important but may not take the spotlight
in this particular point in time what
are the ones what are the ways that we
can tell a story that's not so
um you know uh overt I guess can we tell
stories in ways that are more
um contextual and more suggestive rather
than something that is very um obvious
so I know that seems very like
strange to think about because
surely like with all the voices in my
head it would be confusing or
distracting perhaps but I think it
depends but for me I really want to hear
it all it's kind of like a funnel if you
you know for lack of a better analogy I
want to hear it all I want to hear all
the different perspectives and from
there really be able to hone in and
focus on what's really important what
are the common themes what are the
common patterns what are the common
things people are saying that have a a
unified a more unified
um approach to how we can tell that
story so ultimately once you know you
have all the voices heard and you hear
all the different perspectives you can
have smaller groups and breakout
sessions to consider okay now that we
have this greater idea this big idea
concept of what our project is about now
let's we can go into smaller groups of
like how do we tell that story in this
particular room how do we tell that
story in the dining experience how do we
tell that story in the retail experience
right
so in that sense you can have more
focused groups to think about it but
you know as a Storyteller you you kind
of have to do both you're a generalist
and you're also a specialist when it
comes time for it you really have to
think about how you can use all of these
different stories ideas perspectives in
a much bigger arching story uh story arc
and then find ways in which you can be
more defined and focused in different
elements of your entire experience so
there's different ways that you can do
that but I think that it really depends
on how much time you have you know uh
how much money you have frankly for the
project as well and really think about
how best to approach it and the most
efficient and uh effective way